it's the boulay cab podcast special
guest in here Fendi the rapper is here
welcome yo welcome welcome
um you've had a quite a uh amazing four
weeks or so is that safe to say uh-huh
a month ago do you remember like where
you were follower wise because I think I
feel like I followed you when you're
around like 40 000 and that was maybe
like two weeks ago man yeah
like a month ago I say
I was at
well what I saw was like
16k
that's what I remember seeing it's a big
month you've heard like a hundred and
fifteen thousand yeah yeah yeah yeah
I definitely seen like the last thing I
saw was probably
I wasn't paying attention like that but
I definitely saw 16 yeah I think do you
like when you when you get a big influx
in followers like that
how much of like do you see the famous
blue checks following you like any of
the famous people who you like maybe
grew up watching or checking out like
you're like oh [__] so-and-so's
following me yeah for sure who was like
like two or three of those names where
you were like oh [__]
um well everybody we all just not coming
up but a couple of people that I've seen
that I was like oh [__]
um I say
chlorella glorilla yeah she's great
um
sexy red
um [__]
Fredo bang it was a couple of
[__] I was just like oh [__]
right
yeah if you tap in with sexy where to go
really about working uh working out some
music
yeah I definitely did Asian dial
glow
I mean yeah
sexy sexy red is on fire right she's
cool as hell too like if you ever meet
her she's she's like uh I always say
like when you meet Boosie like he
doesn't disappoint yeah because you know
you'll meet like certain famous people
and you have this like idea who they are
and then you meet him and you're like uh
like when you meet boozy he's exactly
who you think he is yeah yeah when you
meet sexy red she's amazing for sure
she's incredible shout out to her
um how long have you been making music
since like um 2019 I've been taking this
years I just been to welcome to rap
though right you just known this like
since 2012 I've been to I had boss
so what made you like because it's a big
step to break out of your shell and out
of your comfort zone and become
vulnerable in front of a microphone
microphone and all that yeah like 2012
when I was doing it I was just doing
something no trying things with my
friends and then but I knew I had boss
because I thought I tried it I'm like
I'll eat this [__] hard
but then [__]
um time went by I was just I kept doing
it I just didn't take it serious until
2019. what was the difference for you to
start taking it serious
um I had a friend a best friend she
actually inspired me to do this to rap
um she used to be rapping she was real
popular more popular than me and I never
even like took it serious but she always
took it serious she was just like bro
you the rapper I'm I'm just popular or
whatever the case may be but she ended
up passing away in like 2017 and then
I agreed for like two years 2019 came I
got an action [__] for her damn so she's
like the whole inspiration the way
you're doing this [__] literally sure
what's your name tanka rest in peace
yeah rest in peace do you have any
unreleased songs with her that you're
holding on to like no no no no I don't
got no release she got some unreleased
though I'm like [__] I buy hop on that
yeah I gotta find it though I got like
yeah you got to get the file or
something get it on your album yeah for
sure that'd be crazy you grew up in
Chicago yeah South Side uh
I'm like when I think of like female
rappers from Chicago the name that
really comes to mind is Shauna who's
like obviously Sean isn't lucky oh yeah
you know she's like I don't remember
Shawna she was signed a dtp for a little
bit uh I I heard of it remember getting
some head get getting some head oh yeah
yeah I was getting some milk
oh well hold on
yeah oh yeah
she from Chicago she is yeah
damn who are you growing up listening to
in Chicago
CEO my goodies not my goodies Sierra oh
Sierra was great yeah Sierra um
um
Lil Mama my lip gloss is pop that's a
little mama getting some flowers today
feel me little mama for real
um I'm talking about real take it real
back
back back
definitely Chris Brown
love Mama
um
T-Pain you know a little [__] like that
that sounds like what like a 106 and
Park episode from when I was like you
feel me for sure who's the best 106 in
park host is it the OG's is it free in
AJ
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's the
OG's yeah it's free and AJ it's free and
AJ for sure
damn I wish we could have one of them
again
yeah I'm surprised they haven't tried to
I want it to look just like that and I
want them to look just like how they
looked when I was I don't know if that's
gonna happen I know right that's what
I'm saying I think AJ's on Entertainment
Tonight
oh okay I free was doing morning radio
in DC I don't know what happened to free
shout out to her she's a legend but now
that Tyler Perry owns BT
hey maybe he might
bring it back write the check get free
and AJ back together that'd be an
interesting idea Tyler Perry it's not a
crazy idea you know it was like an
obvious idea yeah that's if
[Applause]
for sure